what does it mean to be a mother
it means everything it's it's like a
feeling that it's undescribable love joy
it's a switch cardi B showing just how
much she loves being a mom tattooing her
son's name on her face oh yes honey the
rapper sharing this pic featuring the
new ink wave in red cursive running
along her jawline she simply captions it
I love my face tat and they don't know
how much like that means to me though
cardi hinted she was contemplating
getting her baby boy's name Inked over a
year ago tweeting random but I'm one
percent close to tatting my son's name
on my face I really want to do it
and the tat seems to be a companion
piece to this ink on hubby offset space
he got there now four-year-old daughter
cultures named tatted when she was just
seven weeks old I love everything about
motherhood Cordy first unveiled the
inking in September a month after
getting it done by tattoo artist
Robinson de los Santos
[Music]
and that timing suggests cardi got the
tat in honor of waves first birthday
also in September away
the couple went all out as they usually
do for birthdays
[Music]
happy birthday
and these extravagant celebrations
aren't just to show off cardi once
tweeted I know I can be a little extra
when it comes to my kids but I ain't
really had growing up so yeah I'm a ball
babe boy you had a good time
[Applause]
wants to see and watch and know you just
have to be very overly protective
foreign